well the political season has brought
out the people hating the wealthy again
Bernie Sanders has been all about
redistributing wealth and he just closed
on a $600,000 beach house as a second
home this week which there's nothing
wrong with that I'm a lake house is
worth more than that but I'm not out
preaching wealth equality oh my goodness
are hypocritical aren't we
burn not feeling you not feeling the
burn okay anyway so have you heard that
all wealthy people that the way they get
to be wealthy is is that they inherited
their wealth did you know that that's
mythology nine out of ten of America's
millionaires are first-generation rich
have you heard that all the wealthy
people the way they got wealthy is
they're crooks they stole all the money
or the only way to be wealthy is to be a
famous actor or a famous music star or
famous athlete or you have to be
brilliant you have to have like a 4.2
GPA all of this is mythology I've worked
with the wealthy for 30 years I am now
wealthy and second time I'm so dumb I
had to do it twice so we're going to do
a millionaire theme hour right now and a
millionaire theme hour is this if you
are a millionaire and let me help you
with what a millionaire is in case you
didn't know because some people like
running for office and stuff are stupid
and they don't know the actual
definition of a millionaire a
millionaire is someone with a $1,000,000
or greater net worth your net worth is
defined as an accounting function it's
what you own minus what you owe it's
what you own minus what you owe your
assets minus your liabilities if that
equals 1 million dollars then you're a
millionaire now you may not feel like a
millionaire these days and doesn't buy
as much as it used to but it buys more
than not having a million dollars buys
and so how do you get to be a
millionaire well we're going to talk to
millionaires this hour if you are a
millionaire call me at triple eight
eight two five five two two five we've
lined up a couple to make sure we've got
enough people to talk to
but triple 8 8 to 5 5 2 to 5 and I want
to interview them and let you hear what
it takes to be a millionaire because if
you learn what these folks have done and
then you go do what they have done you
have a higher probability of being a
millionaire than listening to your broke
brother-in-law who has an opinion about
wealth inequality this is how you do it
if you want to be skinny you talk to
skinny people if you want to be wealthy
you talk to wealthy people so I'm going
to interview them and ask them a series
of questions so that you can find out
that their regular folks that they
aren't crooks and then in most cases
they did not inherit their wealth if
they did that's fine we'll mark that
down too but we're going to find out the
real story with real millionaires not
someone with a political agenda not
someone with an axe to grind
Steve's going to start us off in San
Jose California hey Steve how are you
great date how are you doing I am better
than I deserve man so what is your net
worth right now we're at 2.8 million 2.8
and what is that composed of what are
the major components of your net worth
it's 30% real estate 65% mutual funds
and then we have about 5% in cash okay
so real estate and mutual funds and that
includes your home I assume right yes
that's right okay mutual funds like
401ks and that kind of stuff or what
else yeah 401ks IRAs okay and how old
are you I'm just turned 60 and my wife
is 57 okay cool and how much of this
money did you inherit well my about 20
who over 22 years ago I think my wife
inherited $50,000 when I relatives
passed away okay um and that's the
extent of it so virtually none of it all
right out of
like and what has your average working
income been through your working
lifetime well we started a little under
$30,000 many many years ago thirty years
ago and then were the last couple of
years my wife and I had some increases
and so we I retired we were both are
together making about 300,000 okay home
maybe a little little bit over a hundred
thousand I would say over that 30-year
period ruin and and what was your
careers I was an engineer for 32 years
and and my wife will be retiring if
everything goes well at the end of this
year and she's Bill retiring as a chief
of staff for a health insurance company
okay all right and well you haven't
assumed an engineering degree
that's correct Evan I have an
engineering degree and my wife and I
both have MBAs okay all right and what
were your GPA is my GPA enter
engineering was about a three point four
and then through business school is
about three point nine my wife went
through I'd say her GPA was probably
little higher than mine probably maybe
three point five two point six through
her business comm you know through her
first business degree and how much of
the 2.8 million is the result of you
borrowing money to build well following
many to build wealth none you didn't use
debt to build the world okay no we did
not
okay cool and um very cool so what part
has giving played in your financial plan
well over the years my wife and I have
given to our church and to certain
shredder will organizations more
recently we we're helping finance the
education of a couple of one of our
relatives kids and we're going to be
doing that for another relative our kids
are 22 and 26 and they're on their own
so we help them with their education and
so now we're kind of trying to help
other members of our family who we think
could use the help
yeah what's the most expensive pair of
jeans you've ever bought
oh my gosh um I don't know probably
about 20 bucks 25 bucks and I have you
know we've we're tell you I lucky day
because I picked the right spouse we we
actually both picked the right spouse I
think we're kind of low maintenance
people yeah you know we've never been
into fancy cars or boats or soul-winning
pools we have a really nice home but the
the 25 year old version of you is out
there listening what advice would you
give him if he wants to be worth 3.8
million when he's 60 well one thing I
would tell him right off the bat is
avoid getting into debt because if you
don't get into debt you never have to
work your way out of it the second thing
is to prepare a monthly budget and stick
to it
you know we've stuck to our monthly
budget for certain two years with my
wife and I have worked very very hard
we've taken at every advantage we
clicking a working are in our in our
respective fields and also start
standing investing early that's those
are the four things a virus good Jeff
very cool well Steve you're a hero man
honored to talk to you honor to talk to
you you're a capitalist you made it
happen
2.8 million net worth congratulations
this is the Dave Ramsey show on a
millionaire theme hour hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show you can do
this you know that really is a message
whether you've got two hundred seventy
thousand dollars in student loan debt or
27 thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a $500,000
intercom
you